spike my first question is about Heather
who I will note is buried in an unmarked
grave so her grave won't be desecrated
by white nationalists and neo-nazis I'm
gonna talk about Susan bro her mother
and where you were in the making of this
film when Heather was murdered and how
it changed the film that you were making
well I made a mistake in recounting the
story and can and can I got it mixed up
I said that August we we didn't start
shooting to the fall so there's one year
today I didn't I didn't see as David
Chappelle has called him the tiki torch
[ __ ] I didn't see that Friday
night till Saturday and I was in
Martha's Vineyard and I just couldn't
watch anymore
and at that time my house I don't play
golf my house on 18th on Martha's
Vineyard and fate destiny he was teeing
off so I went over to him after he hit
the ball and I told about
Charlottesville and and he said spike I
know you know I've been on the course at
last for four hours so I just found it
even before I told Obama I made up my
mind this is gonna be the end in the
film just day and what you saw was
written by David Duke neo-nazis all
right and the KKK but I knew that I had
to get the blessing of Miz bro so I was
able to get a number and I gave my
condolences the best way you can I mean
what can you really say I'm here
daughter got murdered on national
television and she's seen my films and
she said trust you spike so once I got
the blessing from her that was ending
there's no way no one's gonna be able to
studio whoever was not gonna talk me out
of this was the end of the movie I want
to ask you about the scene with Harry
Belafonte and how that scene was written
and how it was cut and how that seam
came together because it's a beautiful
piece of editing and a really amazing
contrast in two stories well you know
the scenes the indoctrination of the new
clan members and the story of Waco Texas
in 1915 was in the script and I was in
the script in a way of of this is
happening simultaneously and you know
butBut but at the script form you know
you don't have the luxury of actually
already having shot the film and and
being able to say well we can do this so
so it's a lot of times it's a matter of
well let's let's have a block of the
story from Waco and then we'll go we'll
go to two where they're doing the dinner
and then indoctrination but it's really
finally you know in the editing room we
can really really shape it and and have
it really truly become one and I think
that was our idea once you say spike
that it was going to be one and it
wasn't ever going to feel as if
emotionally is got to feel as if they're
intertwined with each other even coming
out of that at the very end and you hear
you had you know the crowd and the and
in the house and their chanting you know
black power black power black power and
then that comes over into into that
scene in which and which David Duke is
about to give a toast and we saw that
that there was a lot of room before
Topher actually finally delivers that
first long and so it was like wow this
is space and and oftentimes you know
it's the kind of space where where you
just
we're gonna cut this down we're gonna
he's gonna he's gonna do the toast right
away but it gave it gave us the
opportunity to you know end that you
know the cutting back and forth by
bringing that chant right into the clan
and and we had and we could do it three
or four times before before at the
beginning of that toast but otherwise a
lot of it was just just I'm sort of an
instinctual editor I don't I don't I
don't think a lot about about what
should work I just I just fall through
it Laura I'm gonna ask you about Patrice
who is a composite character but also
reflects not only a lot of women who
were active in the movement but also in
ideologies that she presented in terms
of you know what the movement could do
so who are the people who were important
to you in terms of your research in
talking to who were actually in the
movement and who were influential and
how you approached this character well
spike initially introduced me to
Kathleen cleaver we we're all able to to
talk to her and hear her story so that
was kind of the the starting point of
researching these people and she was the
basically the person who ran
communications for the Black Panthers
who now teaches at Emory law yes now
she's a law professor at Emory she
started off in snick and she knew
Stokely Carmichael and then moved to
Oakland and joined the Black Panther
Party and then married Eldridge Cleaver
and so they were huge figures in the
movement of course and then I've read a
lot of Angela Davis's books and watched
documentaries watch a lot of interviews
with her and then I contacted the BSU at
Colorado College to speak to people who
were actually there that in the early in
the early 70s and I just talked to
people in my life as well you know my
aunts who were involved in the movement
and so what to my dad and just wanted to
create kind of you know this
amalgamation of the face of the Black
Power movement and I think it's so rare
to see the female side of that and I'm
so thankful for Spike for for allowing
me to play that because
you know I bet at the height of the
Panthers the majority of their members
were women and ends usually when we talk
about these movements it's just really
kind of macho male-driven face and the
women were a huge part of that so I just
wanted to pay homage to them and just
give them you know the respect that they
deserve
topher I can imagine this is a kind of a
good news/bad news call you get from
your age
[Applause]
Spike Lee wants you to this movie you're
playing David Duke I mean and I mean
that's honestly that's a it's it's a
hard thing to convince yourself to do so
what was your thought process about
playing this part in one of the earliest
conversations with Spike about how you
were gonna approach playing David well
the good news was it wasn't like I'd
never met Spike and then he called and
wanted me to do it nobody saw it for me
I begged to read Spike's new film
because I'm such a fan and then I called
my agents and said hey I think I have a
take on David Duke I was like silence
like for the next five or six minutes
but I they what they said is they talked
to spike they said you know it's not
like anything you've done before and
you're gonna have to go in and read for
him and I was happy to do it
one because it's on me to show a proof
of concept but two I kind of wanted to
see if I could do it the night before I
was rehearsing alone what I was gonna
read it was a more inflammatory than so
my dialogue it's in the film when I was
reading what I was gonna read for Spike
and I was alone in my office at home my
wife had gone to sleep and alone in this
room I was like swallowing some of the
words and that's not right for the
character but you're so trained not to
even think those words so the next day
when I went in to meet Spike I kind of
started with a rehearse speech that I
had that was like hey nice to meet you
and also like this is I don't know if
this corny but or if there's annoying
because every actor says this but I'm so
uncomfortable and this is why everyone
has to work with Spike
is he immediately started making me feel
comfortable he's a really funny guy I
don't know if a lot of people know that
about spike but he's really hilarious
and I started feeling so comfortable
that I then like gave a performance to
him that he then cast me and but I
really don't think I would have gotten
the role if not for that exchange so I'm
very grateful to him for that I'm
curious in looking into kwame's work and
hearing what he had to say
what was your way into that character
and then we'll talk a little bit about
the scene at the very beginning of the
film I think my way in was just knowing
that that will won this film had purpose
and and had relevancy to to sort of
everything that's going on right now and
to be honest
anything spike is doing because he's
such you know he is the artist that he
is
you better believe it's gonna have you
know the currency to it and a pulse to
it and so to be able to step into these
shoes I mean for an actor is it's it's
it's one of those things because it's
like it's only a certain amount of time
in a film and it's Spike Lee and you
ain't trying to mess it up and you know
but I just remember him being so he's so
detail-oriented and just about the
research and about about I mean we were
sharing books and you know he's call
he's like man I need you to you know
watch a black pilot mixtape and get over
there and pick it up his on it said
amoeba on Sunset I'm like spike I'm with
friends only but like you know but he's
that he's he's like just get it you know
just but but it was that kind of
attention to detail that allowed me to
just kind of flow and do what I needed
to do the the the message is so heavy
and so necessary from Stokely from Kwame
Toure excuse me but my way in was his
his humor and his charisma his the
things that the people don't know about
him you know his is the smile you know
the jokester
and that came from just studying video
in his Trinidadian that little that he
had when he see you know talk to people
and and just just just that kind of
energy I mean it was it was even our
costume designer Marcy I mean just
having that conversation at forty acres
in the middle of headquarters about what
he was wearing with bracelet you know
and then like did he like his coffee
black girl sugar like you know what I
mean the little stuff that we as actors
just kind of jump into and John David
it's it's not your first Spike Lee film
if people look really closely for
student in Harlem classroom and Malcolm
X where somebody you know your dad
Denzel Washington was acting and so
you're not new to Spike
but you might be new like a lot of
people who are Tehran Stallworth I mean
this book was originally published by a
press that only put out books by police
officers and firefighters that's how
little interest there was in Ron
Stallworth story when it published I
want to ask you about your encounter
with a book and your encounter with Ron
because the book is very much a
procedural this happened and then this
happened what did you learn about the
man and talking to Ron and what was it
that you wanted to capture in his spirit
that may not be flexible flexible a 60s
my way in was music and a lot of Soul
Train at night I was well you to my soul
train and you know this in like Superfly
and just I I was but even before talking
to Ron I was able to contact like my
uncles and and different men of those
that lived in those times just to get an
idea of what it was like you know and it
just seemed like America was just fed up
they were fed up Vietnam the murder of
Martin Luther King JFK and so that
frustration was filtered through you
know positive things like the clothing
the hair did the music you know
entertainment so that was sort of like
the foundation I wanted I needed even
before meeting Ron and also to spy what
let me meet Ron first late he did Mario
18 I was begging him for their numbers
like
every week I'm asking them what can I
get the number not yet not yet I didn't
meet him until the table read and it was
something interesting that happened I
was doing a research I'd you know
obviously from the book and just looking
at different interviews online but it
was interesting hearing them speak about
his experience right before we started
reading the the script back to him as he
was telling us he's passed around that
membership card the KKK membership card
seriously right that's the reaction I
had yeah oh I've seen David Duke
signature on the back and like these
rules says it never happened and then we
passed around the card and since I
signed it he signed it thing up you know
so yeah it was like the book he he off
he was very generous with his time and
information and like the book like just
from the technical standpoint of all
where to stand how to hold your gun
things like that but getting underneath
the surface and and the emotions that
went with living in Colorado Springs I
mean you can make a movie about him even
just being the first african-american
police officer there I mean that let
alone the sting operation and that was
very helpful some of the personal things
that we talked about that I cannot share
with you all and I exchanged some
personal stuff of my own you know and
and and sort of this mission that I
can't ask and I will say I kept asking
me you didn't get emotional I want black
did you ever say did you ever get too
emotional or what and he said no it was
always about the job it was always about
the job and I and and that day at the
banquet the banquet saying that was the
toughest day for me too because now that
sort of like the car gave me this sort
of portal to his soul again and that
like this man was staring death and
hating the eye and he had the law on his
side he still could have got buried and
nobody heard of him so III called him
that after that scene it was like your
hero man like American hero for real how
does the conversation change outside
this film what do you hope people are
talking about in the weeks and months
and years ahead I think that
conversation exchanged ideals can work
but we have to come from a place of
truth and I think that for me and this
is an
they want to enter tonight on this note
that we had to deal with the history of
this country if we don't acknowledge
that the United States was built upon
the genocide of Native people and
slavery then what's the point because
you don't deal with the foundation the
origin the basic fabric then then we're
not gonna get anywhere because that has
led to white supremacy which is know
where we are today the stuff where that
we're taught I was taught public school
Brooklyn New York you know that lie
about George Washington the cherry tree
I was not taught that George Washington
slaves Thomas Jefferson I mean first by
eight nine nude Google that's the legacy
of this country you go to the
Constitution it says slaves with wood
you could read it Google three-fifths of
you and being I'm not making up read it
three fifths so that's we have to get to
the basics and then once we get there
then we can move forward otherwise we
will be talking about the same thing
hundred years from now so goodnight get
home safely